like i would imagine hundreds if not
thousands of other families
were incandescent with rage because what
this
proposal of legislation is going to be
allowing will be in essence
giving murderers a license to kill
because as long as any future terrorist
organization and trust me there'll be
some
waiting in the wings and this must be
music to their ears
as long as they come with a political
stance of
we are fighting for our political
freedoms or whatever
they can kill thousands and thousands of
people
in any of our cities without any fear of
retribution
of prosecution or any
criminal prosecutions whatsoever what
kind of a society
are we planning for our future
generations
i chose not to have children i'm not
strong enough to have children
losing maxine had such a massive effect
on me
that the thought of having a child and
then potentially losing that child
i am not strong enough to cope i don't
know how our mother has coped
and i don't know how all the other
parents have coped
this legislation
is basically writing off any history
that our loved ones ever existed
and that's what it's all about this is
for the governments
and their predecessors to bury their
dirty
toxic pasts and for
them to never ever see the light of day
the rhetoric that brandon lewis was
coming out with
is obscene and abhorrent
to our ears how is it possible that a
government
in a country that claims to have a
judicial system that's the envy of the
world
is considering implementing legislation
that will allow mass murderers to have
their liberty
can you imagine if the americans gave
amnesty to the boston
bomber the
public anger that was seen last january
in washington would be an afternoon tea
party in comparison
and yet they expect us to sit back and
take this
lying down what people need to
understand
about the troubles is that the british
state had had infiltrated both
the ira and the loyalist side so much so
that it could be argued that they are
the british states are also complicit
in many of the murders and the perp the
sole purpose of this legislation there's
no issue no but
please do not be blinded by all the
rhetoric and
so-called reconciliation how can there
possibly be
reconciliation julia this is
it's it's so hard i know how upset you
are
this will drag up all of those painful
memories
about maxine and you live with this
every day
and today is the height of that emotion
what the government is saying what
they've eventually
what they've essentially said is that
some families will never get justice
um instead the focus is going to be on
information
recovery for families of those killed
what brandon lewis said
was that the current system isn't
working he said
this is the best and only solution for
victims
and their families that he said is the
painful
reality do you think there is another
way
because brandon lewis pointed out when
his opposite number on the labor bench
is said
everything she had to say echoing what
you're saying he came back and said
labor have not offered another solution
the process of getting justice in these
historical cases is so complex
the government feel that this is the
best solution that victims may not get
justice now because of the statute of
limitations
but people may be more forthcoming with
answers
i think i know the answer to this but
for many families they may not get
justice
will they be satisfied with finding out
more and getting answers
without it ending in prosecution
no no and that this
this rubbish talking about
reconciliation reconciliation and truth
even even if that was to come to pass
who's to say that the person
talking will actually be telling the
truth because most of them
wouldn't know how to spell the word let
alone speak it
and as far as uh that there there are
there's no evidence there
and that it's just too late to bring
about prosecutions
that is another load of utter rubbish
the evidence is there
it's just that it's been hidden and the
purpose and the priority of
this government and past successive
governments
is to keep their collusion with
both sides of the ira and the loyalists
is to keep their dirty toxic secrets
well and truly buried do you need to
fight this people will you fight this
for us to absolutely of course we will
fight it
let's see
today no please carry on
sarah jane today that they have married
that they have buried
a young lad who is stabbed to death down
the road from where i live
dijon god bless him may he rest in peace
can you imagine if dijon's mother
and brother and family were to sit back
and listen to the similar rhetoric that
we've just had to sit and listen to
by brendan lewis and by boris johnson
jumping to his
defense after kia stammer thank you very
much highlighted our campaign
and other people's sitting back and
taking it and saying
well there's not enough evidence there
and it's very complex
of course it's complex of course it's
challenging and you know why it's
complex and challenging
because they've got too much to hide
because the predecessors of
of past governments have got our loved
ones blood
on their hands and they want to do
everything that is in their power
to keep their collusion well and truly
buried and we will not sit back
and allow our loved ones to be forgotten
about
and the other issue is that of course
it's complex
and the reason why it's complex is
because all governments
refuse to have any dialogue with the
victims of these terrorist attacks
we have never ever been acknowledged by
any government irrelevant to what
political party
today has been the most significant day
for the birmingham
bombing families where kierstama
referred to me by name which we were
very grateful for
louise hague has referred to us and
other families in northern ireland
but there are so many other families the
omar in a skill in bala murphy
the um the london wharf bombings the
um uh
um all those families today you're
representing all those families today
these families
and you're doing you're doing a sterling
job at representing those families and
their feelings today you mentioned the
fact that zakir stama
brought you up um in the house of
commons today i just want to read you
the prime minister's statement because
sakia stamina said
what does the prime minister have to say
to julie because she is listening
and other victims like her the prime
minister boris johnson said i think the
whole house will acknowledge the
suffering of victims like julie and
their families
and of course nothing i can say or do
now will mitigate her loss
but it is also true that the people of
northern ireland must
if we possibly can allow them to must
move forward
it is impossible it is absolutely
impossible
to move forward until truth
justice and accountability is seen to
be done the purpose of this legislation
is to cover up to
the true scale of the exposure
of the british state in the past and
that
is what this is all about it's a smoke
screen
and until they go into dialogue
with the victims on both sides of
the troubles only then can there
be some answers but the problem is we're
not only with the conservatives but
labour too and i've told that the labour
the labour mps have taken the time to
speak to us the same thing
until they listen to us and all
the others only then can there be a path
towards peace and prosperity
and some kind of calmness
not just in in northern ireland but also
within uh the mainland of england too
where many
many families have suffered the loss of
their loved ones there are just too many
suffering and
we cannot allow ourselves even for our
future generations
how can we possibly wake up tomorrow
morning or in months to come
having had this legislation being
implemented
knowing that our children and our
children children could be walking down
the street one day
be blown up and then in years to come
the very same terrorists who murdered
them
walk away scot-free because the british
government
put into legislation in 2021 that you
can kill
whoever you like wherever you like on
british soil
because it was for a political stance
who on earth in what country
what in the western society would allow
that to go through